hallo allerdings freunde ihr seht ja
bereits was ich mich dann nicht von
meinem schreibtisch befindet sondern in
meiner küche und dass sie ganz einfach
daran dass ich heute kochen zusammen
wird
und 10 die kann ich koche ich habe keine
feste genutzt
hätte auch flaschen ist übrigens die
wöchentliche lösung für eine ausgewogen
und lecker ernährung also lange die
nicht wissen was das ist ohne
mindestlaufzeit und verpflichtungen der
head of fresh box bestellt bestehend aus
drei gerichten und sandra dachte das
gericht aussuchen was sie jetzt kochen
will und zwar hinten im becken mantel
zwischendurch ja das tut richtig netter
klatsche doch einmal kürzen die sagen so
erhalten
wir fragen jetzt einfach mal an leute
daher oft bekommt man übrigens nicht nur
die sachen mehr geliefert sondern dazu
auch das passende rezept
selbstverständlich deswegen würde ich
sagen wir fahren einfach direkt an dem
österreich allererstes das gemüse
vorbereiten das heißt die knobloch
zuallererst müssen wir die
knoblauchzehen abziehen und die
kartoffeln geschält je nach größe
vierteln oder halbieren chopin
kartoffeln
zwischendurch macht die wir sofort weg
stürzt sich luca auf meine mami waren
meine stimme zu
[Musik]
was ich habe
von bob der baumeister
leider gebraucht meinte ist ja vorhin
was auch schon mal auf deutsch gekocht
habe ja was hat sie besonders gut
gefallen
genug also ich habe mich mit dir das wir
kommen ja ich weiß genau was dort
gekocht ja und jetzt nicht liegt
hallo ich find's gut dass man keine
lebensmittel web werde ich koche und ich
wurde alleine schmeißt man leider schon
einiges weg kann man ja nicht jeden tag
kartoffeln essen kann ja das ist halt
das ding sondern sich kartoffeln kauft
kauft man heute im supermarkt immer so
gefühlt zehn tonnen kartoffeln sondern
samstag und das häkchen fast nicht von
der größe und man hat immer zu viele
tomaten und keine ahnung was ist das
gerade frisch geliefert wirklich genau
in die portionen wie man es auch
benötigt das man schmeißt euch übrigens
auch fragt wie der ganze prozess abläuft
das ist auch total easy also geht
einfach auf die website könnt euch dann
eure rezepte aufrufen auf dem bock habt
bestellt ihr einkommen dann werden die
euch ein paar tage später kostenlos
zugestellt wie sich die tomaten klein
die sonst
drauf
ich war traurig guckt noch mal rezept
ja
da hat es vielleicht doch vielleicht
könnte übrigens auch eure bedürfnisse
aus wird also beispielsweise vegane
rezepte nur anzeigen lassen vegetarisch
familienrezepte schnelle rezepte ihren
familien genommen wir sind keine familie
you wish das geld auch was ist jede
woche wirklich neue geile rezepte gibt
es ist tot es unkompliziert man das mega
flexibel mann hatte eine geisteskranke
zeitersparnis und das online gestellt
die sachen kommen hat einfach an man
muss nicht im supermarkt laufen es ist
genau die richtige portion wieder
draußen locken luca ich bin einfach ein
genauer kopf
und zu machen die gassen man die kosten
wären wir das alles übrigens gerade
vorbereiten ein zuge selbstverständlich
unsere rufen schon auf 220 grad und
sofort
perfekt haben übrig hatte der kamera
ich bin am dunking von paus und soll
wenn die kameraeinstellung nicht ganz
optimal sind aber ich bin noch dabei
knoblauch eine schade vermengen das mit
12 nationen öl und wird das alles mit
salz pfeffer um das dann über unser
vergleich zu stellen oder über sandra
dies wenn sie stinkt
ganz viel salz das ganz ganz viel zeit
sagt stock
wirklich
sagte schütz komplett einfach mal dass
meine
macht spaß kochen mit samba mir macht es
das rezept ist lecker aber du störst
mich ich würde gerne alleine machen er
halte ich auch viel mehr spaß und viel
mehr nur und keiner meckert mich an
keiner nervt mich keiner gibt mir
anweisungen
aber du kannst es ja ganz easy zu hause
kochen denn ich habe ja auch ein code
für dich dann spare
denn mit dem kot helau luca erhaltet ihr
bis zu 80 euro rabatt auf eure
bestellung natürlich demnach box größe
und nur für neukunden und konnte dann
aber
schon eine infobox das 103 links ist für
deutschland österreich schweiz
den apparat soll jetzt können wir hier
natürlich bei meinem super offen
einstellen garzeit 25 minuten es heißt
25 drin lassen ich mag sagt frost ist
werden auch
wir können uns jetzt umziehen im
beckmann wir setzen jetzt nämlich jedes
viele hier vorne mit salz und pfeffer
und werden das dann mit bacon um
maschinen
[Applaus]
wir fordern unsere fahne jetzt vor den
entsprechend legen wir unser hähnchen
herein in manchen werken manchen und der
herd erhitzen das jetzt große zweites
kleinen kompakten stand für die letzten
zwölf minuten nochmal mit dem was ich
jetzt nicht festlegen lassen
der wird ja auch immer mit dem rad
fender
haben wenn dort ein damaliges jahr zum
arzt er auch für leute die keine ahnung
vom kochen haben das hat perfekt gemacht
sie ist das perfekte beispiel als
würdest du besser kommen können jetzt
wieder weg wenn ich sie einmal kurz hier
möchte ich mag
sie sehen ich stehe natürlich viel über
die leinwand
ja heißt so
wir packen das jetzt gefahren hat
einfach aus dass wir auch in unserem
open ließen ihn ruft wiederum warten
jetzt die letzten minuten nochmal ab und
in der zeit machen wir unsere busse gibt
nämlich die samen rein sodann ist
basilikum festung verwandelt das alles
umzusetzen ist dann je nach bedarf mit
salz und pfeffer mich sagen haben wird
komplett für sich
jetzt die soße ist wird so ein bisschen
aufkochen lassen schneidet sandra unsere
blätter schon zurecht die nehmen sich
blasen blasien truppen war selig das
wollte ich im nächsten tag sagen aber
das scheint mit basilikum das packen
jetzt gleich ein wunderschönes war
vieles fertig weil die freunde 100 ganze
jetzt mal raus stellt sie hin sander
bereitet wir vorne noch die große finale
auf die basilikumblätter eingemachte
vermengen jetzt noch mal und wir richten
das ganze jetzt schön an nur wenige
minuten später um leute das essen ist
fertig habe ich kann ja schon mal die
kleine nach aufnahme machen es sieht
wirklich tot ist so schon
ich dachte warten und erzählt erstmal
noch mal kurz das volk eine so
ausgewogene ernährung geht schnell
keinen stress ganz einfach online
bestellen software ist
hotel luca 80 euro rabatt auf eure
erstbestellung neukunden kommt je nach
box muss
wie schmeckt 4
kein schalter ich weiß dass hier werbung
ist aber es ist wirklich nicht nicht
gerade irgendwie auch geschmeckt und
fast immer wild echte wichtigkeit
nur
verächtlich
schaut man die infobox da findet ihr
alle links erklärungen um nochmal
leistenbruch da
die harmoniert den tisch
gelegt auf die glocke wenn sie verpassen
wollt und wenn ihr bauch weitere kaufen
das konzert dann
welche nicht